but you don't need to know that this is
sucking money that's a TMI
even if we were cool like I wouldn't be
like yo I took it up
sacrifice you did for me yeah your
parents want to be cool with that if I
was sucking like toys and stuff no but
your mom would be like what the hell I
didn't do I did the same thing I don't
get no money
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
careful boys today we have a special
guest we have Kazumi with us
foreign
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah because it's he likes anime
everybody got a horny name come on
that's good a good Asian boy question
are you a good Asian way okay
this is for all the Asian good Asian
boys out there what got you into uh
motion pictures for the adult uh vision
and this is only for Asian boys to know
for Asian parents I feel like such a
it's such a rock star it's such a rock
star move you're not a lot of Asian pair
of subscribers because in an Asian
parent's eyes if you join theater you're
already a porn star yeah so you went
like full-on if you're Asian eyes it's
like
doctor or pharmacist right and then even
if you're like gonna be an engineer you
might as well be important
[Laughter]
my parents don't know what I do
what you gotta be kidding I just talked
about like cryptocurrency until they
tell me to shut the [ __ ] up like stop
[ __ ] talking they don't know what you
do that's the best maintained kept
secret but also it's just like we got
beef like you know like when you're like
an Asian oldest daughter like immigrant
daughter and you're like 19. it's like
me and my dad we got beef like I'm not
talking to you dude so what's the point
yeah so I'll tell him like a little
something and I'll like pay for all the
Christmas gifts but you don't need to
know that this is dick sucking money
that's a TMI I also wouldn't tell you
even if we were cool like I wouldn't be
like yo I took it up the ass that's
crazy
damn but I think you would actually
appreciate the gifts a little bit more
knowing that you know what I mean
you asked for this Nerf gun is that what
you did yeah
for you I thought about you I actually
think parents would like that because
they'll be like the sacrifice you did
for me yeah I kind of disagree but yeah
you're totally right your parents want
to be cool with that yeah I don't think
if I was sucking dick for like toys and
stuff no but your mom would be like what
the hell I didn't do I did the same
thing I don't get no money
there's lines to this game but there are
[ __ ] lines
you're eating booty for free everyone
does it everybody does it that's true my
mom
they both did it they both did it okay
just because you bring your mom back
into it's okay now we're all full-grown
cream pies
we're well fermented yeah yeah I made it
that's it but you don't think they
suspect I think I don't think they could
um tell the levels of depravity of like
what of what all I've done they could
probably tell I'm like I'm a silly
little girl they could probably tell I'm
a little silly and I might be a little
different so their imagination won't go
that way yeah I don't think they're
thinking about like gang bangs and stuff
I'm thinking like okay she probably just
has Reckless and danger but you don't
think like your dad get horny sometime
he'd be like shut up he probably looks
at me
because of any fans girl primer primary
which is exclusive and then I'm
practiced so that's exclusive side so
unless he has a subscription he's not
gonna find [ __ ] yeah and if you find it
then you're subscribed so that's a uh
are you are you never scared of like
haters grabbing your content and then
like mass mailing your parents that
would probably make me shart myself I
but I've actually said this in like
every podcast ever and it just hasn't
happened so don't do it
don't do it yeah just subscribe to her
only fans don't be a weirdo I mean if
you want to see my boobs you could just
see my boobs like what that hurts nobody
like you know and it's true it's almost
free my only pants is three dollars
that's pretty good oh yeah I want a low
I got five dollars in my pocket right
now
you can't even last two months
[Laughter]
but I started doing porn because well I
was a marketing executive prior so I had
like good knowledge on and I also was a
loser so I was on the internet so I knew
how to navigate like social media pretty
well but before that I would go to like
parties and just get [ __ ] in front of
everyone like all the time which is kind
of a silly little so you did it for free
for fun anyway yeah so I was going
and getting railed but like you're into
it though yeah yeah no no obviously
that's you that was like yeah I mean
she's like no I'll Go's non-consensual
all the time well they're not like that
but I'm saying like
but I just like to perform and I like to
practice like I remember one of the
first parties I went to ever I was like
19 and I was doing this like like silly
little orgy in front of a bunch of
people and it was a silly little Origins
they're just like a mosh bit of dudes
just jacking off everywhere just like
everywhere around just watching like my
little circle yeah what kind of parties
are they this is just a silly little
party it's just like a Century City
I'm like I've never been to one of these
parties is it on Vine it was like a sex
club party it was it was like it had
like beds everywhere oh yeah is this
like like in in California or this was
in the valley but this was not for porn
this was like back when I was 19 just
just being silly is my favorite word
because it's the best thing it covers a
lot of sins yeah yeah so I was just
doing that and eventually my friends and
I were like dude all the people here are
old and ancient let's like start like
making our own like sexy Fight Club
where we kept inviting sexy people
there's sex [ __ ] each other
so we I started having my own sex club
throwing my own sex parties like every
Friday and I would just invite all those
people I wouldn't always [ __ ] as I would
just bring to snacks you know sometimes
silly snacks
should I bring back the school the gummy
worms and the cost of chicken wrap
sandwiches you know whoa what a combo
yeah yeah that's the world I didn't even
know existed but you watch movies you're
like oh there's like worlds like that
you're not a silly guy you're not a
silly guy you're a good Asian boy I know
well he's not that either but yeah I am
still going to those parties nowadays
but now that I do porn and it's super
controlled and I'm responsible I get
tested every seven to ten days so I'm
just like oh we're called it no
back then a miracle I'm alive Tennessee
yeah what were the precautions you took
back then to being an irresponsible 19
year old just partying yeah well I was
everyone wore condoms and everything and
it was also like you would it was up to
your own jurisdiction of like how if
they had their own tests and people
still have fancy people sex parties
nowadays it's like the masks and [ __ ]
but yeah that's how I started the
closest thing that I've seen to that was
um when we were like DJing this guy
booked a venue out for his birthday and
he told us to come check it out so we
can like hook up all the equipment right
so when we went in there was this
[ __ ] Warehouse in like Long Beach
like that sounds corny already yeah it's
like a regular Commercial Warehouse you
see like shipping [ __ ] trucks whatever
right wow and it's like a clean
corporate style like this one
and then we went in and there's like
these double doors and then you go
through it and it looks like a regular
club with that Velvet Rope [ __ ] and then
you go inside and then there's like beds
oh yeah yeah like the whole wall is just
like bed after bed after bed after bed
and a big [ __ ] mirror on and then
each room is themed like one's got like
that lipstick couch and like different
[ __ ] with like handcuffs if the lipstick
counts
yeah there's just beds everywhere but it
looks kind of like those um kind of
cheesy hotel rooms but with no walls I
just came from
a sort like last week it's like that
yeah
yeah I got Mega rail it was crazy yeah
yeah what's what's Mega is there like
ultra rare like what yeah what's the
difference between regular Rail and the
mega rail I think regular
as you go on vacation for a week and
then you maybe [ __ ] like one shorty
right it's cool me I was busy but it was
kind of cool because like since it was a
swingers resort we were under like
different social constructs so like the
rules of this game just made more sense
like I would talk to a group of guys and
I'd be like hey what's up you want to
smash and they'd all be like yeah yeah
and I and it wouldn't be like homie
hopping in a [ __ ] shaving way it was
just kind of like okay this girl's here
we're all here for the same thing
yeah that this thing is a membership
club the owner told me oh the one that I
would he said that to be a part of it
you have to either be invited if you're
single male or it's a a couple's today's
video is brought to you by DraftKings
the NFL playoff picture is locked in and
my go-to place for Wild Card round
action is DraftKings Sportsbook an
official sports betting partner of the
NFL to kick off the road to Super 57 new
customers can just bet five dollars and
get 200 and free bets instantly plus all
new and existing customers can get a no
sweat bet each day of the Wild Card
round this weekend just place any NFL
bet of your choice and if it loses
you'll get a free BET back up to ten
dollars action's so good why bet NFL
playoffs anywhere else so right now the
playoffs are just starting and it's the
best time to bet if you like playing
games like this because everyone's
pretty much evenly matched it's equal
and that's how they like to have it but
then there's the market bets they're
telling me Oh this guy's the underdog
this guy's a favorite so if you know
what you're looking for you can bet on
the right teams and make some money
because there's like betting lines
exposing the cracks and you know you
could make some opportunity moves right
here baby download the DraftKings
Sportsbook app and use code off the
Record new customers can bet five
dollars on the NFL and get 200 and free
bets instantly only at draftking
Sportsbook with the code off the Record
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply see show notes for details couples
can come single females all can come but
so single males alone can't join and
then there's like a membership fee and
it's a single men thing then it becomes
a gangbang super fast and unless it's
specifically gangbang time that's kind
of like
balance out the ratio
yeah that's normal Club rules I've been
to sex clubs where I had to send in a
head shot and they've been like nah and
I'm like no they're like you're not
pretty enough like that damn well I'll
send it so I have a partner I'm in an
open relationship and he also is able to
see other women so we'll like to come in
as a unit and then they'll be like okay
what if it's just me as like a single
lady I feel like I'm not like hot enough
to come as a single like human
flashlight
that's wild that's crazy so that's super
fascinating how did you get into this
world I feel like well now I'm like
super plugged up because I did those sex
parties for a long time so I just kind
of know like events we're kind of
plugged up like all types of plucked up
but like like you're very intro to it
like voyeurism or like getting [ __ ]
like like in front of people's on a
serious sense I wanted to explore my own
sexual experiences without a man like
influencing that so I went to my I found
my own events Miracle I'm alive bro
because what the [ __ ] like I would like
and then you're just like I'm looking
for you went straight for orgy like you
lost your virginity this way yeah no no
oh okay you need to a normal dude oh
cause I was like damn you went straight
to orgy for your first sexual experience
no but like after we broke up I was
looking for like stuff like that and I
had found a guy and he brought me to a
sex club and [ __ ] was cool and then I
went to my own like I started in like
exploring like furry parties and people
wearing diapers and BDSM stuff and
gangbang stuff and I was just and you
Google these things like how do you is
it on Yelp
my search is different than yours my
Instagram algorithm is probably way
different than yours oh yeah yeah I'm
not getting the good stuff
good stuff switch it up start changing
that there's like
there's like Kink event that I think you
would like and it's all Beauty BDSM and
it's all Asian women and dominatrix
outfits can I tell you something I don't
even know what BDSM stands for I don't
either I see it all the time and I'm
like I don't know is it London
you say batboy it's when you use
whippiness on the butt but what's that
what's you already grew up with that so
he wouldn't want that you have just
missionary for the like purpose of
procreation like
what do you think each letter stands for
I know it has to do with the whippy
whips and the what's the B what's the B
and the ball guys
dominatrix dominating Dominator
submissive
submissive okay
oh serpent master all right what's up oh
no no
umasso chip masochist bondage you don't
even know you [ __ ] cheated she's gone
it's definitely that genre big big sex
mom
so you Google the club and then you
decided I'm gonna [ __ ] do it you
can't really
and then like I feel like being like a
19 year old Asian woman I just
experienced an amazing amount of Club
Privilege where people want to keep
inviting me because different events
there's not enough women there yeah
they're like yes gold is just walking in
here yeah and I was like DTF and also
just a silly fun girl so I so I would
just keep getting invited to more events
and eventually like now I've seen like a
lot of like different things I once went
to this
um sex club in Fort Lauderdale that had
a Hibachi station in the middle of it
they're like making a train while you're
getting trained it's like literally the
future can you imagine [ __ ] someone
and then walking in line butt ass naked
and this lady is making you like your
perfect omelette like you choose like
the little the [ __ ] onion [ __ ]
volcano
they also had the game like a sports bar
so you could watch the game
all at the same time that's way more
efficient for our time than the normal
Club
I mean that's actually like why you know
a lot of people go out to clubs right to
like get down might as well just like
get straight to it
get some shrimps look in your mouth yeah
yeah showers I might as well live there
I might oh that's an equinox yeah
they should call it [ __ ] Ox your life
is like John Wick you know that yeah
kill the dog yeah no no he saved the dog
but all the rooms he goes to where he's
like shooting people up it's just people
[ __ ] and I'm like what kind of hotel
is this yeah secret society people are
just [ __ ] on the side just the Hilton
or the Marriott because the Suites are
big and they have multiple beds please
keep letting me in those hotels I need
them they're very I need them so it
seems like it seems like like this is
like a lot of like fun and a lot of
silly times but there's times where like
it's not so silly not so funny you know
what I would say I was really really
lucky to enter it at first of all at a
young age and like enter communities
that are really safe because like they
really taught like all the guys there
like if you're a [ __ ] weirdo like the
community is so small and so underground
you get like your ass kicked oh word
cool I remember there was this one time
I was at this game gangbang party right
I was not getting gangbanged I was just
in the audience like just seeing these
words these are silly words silly words
silly I'm just saying you're like oh
this girl was laying down right she was
getting like demolished and this guy
comes in he's about to enter her and one
of the guys is like these women have
been through enough you stink bro you
need to take a [ __ ] shower and this
guy was like bro whatever so he tries to
enter her and he was like these women
have been through enough I think Trojan
kicked this guy oh [ __ ] like Sparta
Sparta and he like came talk like it's
like no way with the boner he's flying
back
no
damn like it was a very safe environment
and I felt very comfortable like I feel
like when I go to normal clubs now I
feel really anxious because I don't
really trust a normal guy to understand
all these it's true
there's probably thirstier dudes at a
normal Club I feel like where's security
yeah where's over there like we have a
naked man protecting you too like is it
okay and yeah there's a guy who Spartan
Kick me kick your all these guys with
hard dogs she's [ __ ] enough
I was like w for women's rights thank
you yeah yeah that's hilarious it's
probably because everyone wants to
protect the safe space they know like
how easily this could probably get
ruined right so they're like I need to
come back next week don't [ __ ] ruin
this for everybody yeah it's just like
if this like this is totally it's legal
to have group sex but obviously if like
there's like 50 people having group sex
and like the cops came in that's kind of
a weird situation you know so like let's
make sure everyone's having a good
[ __ ] time and literally yeah a good
[ __ ] time for real
nice do you know any cops no cause I
know some horny ass cops me too I think
it's 99 of them actually I think all
cops are probably a little horny because
they want to [ __ ] this and they're not
in in in the in the groups in in the
rail maybe they don't tell me they're a
cop which I feel like they're bad don't
fall out
I would tell you to leave now do you
have uh like uh things that are like
just ruin your mood like like that kills
it for you I don't like it if okay it's
okay for me personally if you're gonna
jack off to whatever I'm doing but I
need like a covet six foot space bro
like he's like [ __ ] an inch away like
the first time I brought my partner to a
sex club
right stop it stop he obviously
I'm super nervous because he was like oh
my God there's just everyone watching
and my girlfriend
where she can only come if 50 guys are
jacking off that's your Kink I think
yeah yeah yeah and I think 50. wait
that's the only way you can come that's
a rough number I mean just yeah but Plus
or mine is four she's a performer dude
but like so they were my boyfriend was
eating me out and then he looked up and
there was just a guy just like on him
and he was just like this is just my
favorite fantasy just watching you eat
this girl out and he was like can I open
your face please oh well I'm just
talking to him like six feet away could
be cool your dick is too excited
I remember my friends damn some guys are
thirsty this guy wanted my friend to
[ __ ] his wife right so he did and he was
like the guy was like tell me when
you're gonna come like tell me an
extremely naughty YouTube video
but so my this guy wanted my friend to
[ __ ] his wife right and my friend was
like sure and that guy kept being like
please stop moving account please don't
know you're gonna come and he was like
okay I'm gonna come and then as soon as
he's about to come that guy moves his
wife out the way to get the load all
over him
oh that's a bait and switch I was like I
don't know how I feel about that I don't
know oh word is that gay no it's not
um that's kind of gay did he get
something in his mouth I think Gay's
okay right so it's like yeah if you got
nutted on it that part is gay he hasn't
it's not that if it's right or wrong we
just want to know if it's gay or not I
think he just wanted nut on his face but
they didn't touch each other it was just
like right no I still no it touched
something I think it's still a little
gay that's like spitting in his mouth
yeah that's kind of gay I don't ever
want someone else's sperm on me
but what about your sperm on someone
else I don't think I want that either if
it's not a dude if it's a dude
oh [ __ ] no I said dude that's the latest
showing bro does it matter where it
lands like I mean yeah you don't follow
it wherever it goes down the drain and
everything like I don't even like it
when it lands on the sheets it's like
when you die it's like who cares like
it's over like whatever yeah right no
but I'm more of a follow-through guy you
know like the proper the proper like for
the property
but a proper formula is like I mean the
form is like this right what so after
you shoot the basketball goes through
the hoop and the satisfaction goes comes
from you holding that form after the
ball goes through the neck okay
same thing with fighting right without
it you hit someone uh satisfaction comes
from this guy landing on the ground
you're still there when I bust when I
bust I the satisfaction continues
depending on where it lands and if it
goes no
no
Mom
how dare you oh thank you what did you
order this [ __ ] morning steak and
eggs well you're wearing one shoe right
now I only wear one shoe did you order
food right now yeah steak and eggs it
really did get your protein in bro
talking about sex really makes them
hungry you're hungry boy okay I think I
understand the ad I came out my face on
accident before you want your own face
oh we're out of time
One Last Story one time sorry one time
I've never swallowed I think it's
disgusting what I know I know
ladies are like that's like the Pinnacle
of King but that's gross and I I'm not
mean necessarily but it was like please
and I was like could you please taste
test yourself first before you make me
eat it I just think it's really polite
that's true I can see that okay and he
got a spoon which a spoon who are these
guys and he like distinguished like
little [ __ ] spoons and he drank it
like he ate it and he was like you don't
have to swallow and I was like oh he
didn't even wow and that guy is a bold
man yeah yeah you would have a girl
swallow not knowing what she taste like
don't put that on me put it on him what
it tastes like a couple of times because
this one girl she uh
I busted in her mouth and then she saved
it to make out with me in my mouth and I
said why you do that and she thought it
was funny and then next time she was she
she said that you know what we make me
happy I'll say what she goes if you
[ __ ] me and then you suck it out
after and I was like oh God the things I
do to make you happy so you did it
baby called my little janitor like he
would eat the cream pies out of me but
she did somebody else's cream you know
how I was doing it someone else is
[ __ ]
oh
it was emotional for you
yeah that's what happened
[Music]